good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
50 real snapchats from real snapchatters
let's get right to it
everything about Indianapolis race day
favorite TV show the Americans not just
the best show about spies on TV also the
best show about marriage on TV how are
the puff levels a little too high
actually hold on yeah that's better
any great movies to recommend I really
love both dope and the end of the tour
why do you love writing for me it's like
the number one way of escaping the
prison of my consciousness biggest
lesson from the refugee camps I'd never
really considered the horror of
dislocation like it's one thing to
experience trauma inside your community
and in a social structure you understand
but it's totally different to experience
loss at a place that isn't yours
surrounded by people you don't know
where do you see yourself in ten years I
don't know but I know what I want to be
doing on Tuesdays favorite why a debut
of 2016 it hasn't come out yet but
spontaneous is the best book about
spontaneous combustion you will ever
read hints about your new book huh it
concerns the White River when's it gonna
come out I don't know not this year what
do you think of Hamilton it's just so
astonishingly good it's so nuanced and
rich and the songs are so catchy
favorite Hamilton song that's like
asking me to pick between my kids but I
am pretty fond of the cabinet meeting
rap battles can you name a character in
your new book Avery no I can't just like
choose actually you know I kind of like
that name maybe
how many Katherine's qualifies as an
abundance mm 19 possibly 18 what was
your childhood best friend's name ya
know that adorable puppy filter is not
going to trick me person who is clearly
trying to learn the answer to my
security questions what was your dream
job as a kid earthworm scientist how
would you get away with murder well
given that 40% of murders in
Indianapolis go unsolved it's apparently
not that difficult favorite piece of
furniture this lazy boy in which I've
written at least part of all my books
and which was described by The New
Yorker as quote grubby and quote oatmeal
colored and by The Wall Street Journal
as quote tan that's right my lazy boys
been covered by some of America's finest
periodicals and yet does lazy boy send
me recliners for free no they don't
should I read The Fountainhead but there
are so many good books what's your
opinion on sporks I guess I just feel
like they're not very good at two things
honest opinion on Donald Trump I'm
reminded if something Cyrus Chang once
said never wrestle with a pig you get
filthy and besides the pig likes it
what's your favorite reading position
the
do you write with music or in silence
usually silence occasionally the
mountain goats span do you most
listened-to
definitely the mountain goats followed
by Hank green and the perfect strangers
favorite Hank song strange charm who the
eff is Hank Hank is a young adult novel
published in 2005 unfortunately I have
no control over the movie rights to Hank
and he news on the Looking for Alaska
movie
sadly no thoughts on Doctor Who I am
very excited for the new spin on series
written by my friend Patrick Ness have
you ever shaved your head yeah in high
school they shaved my head and then when
it started to grow back I dyed my hair
fuchsia plum but I had a really bad
reaction to the hair dye so I ended up
with a lot of fuchsia plum dandruff and
I was so stressed out about my fuchsia
plum dandruff I'm so glad I'm not in
high school anymore what is this I
believe that's a sloth through having
eaten too much oversized lollipop is now
barfing a rainbow how do I survive
reading Macbeth I think you have a much
better chance of surviving at than
Macbeth does favourite tree
I guess former Orlando Magic player tree
Rollins favorite season oh definitely
season Kent the music supervisor for the
phone their stars in Paper Towns movies
favorite dad joke I'm pretty fond of the
ones I just told are you making a
Cooking Channel maybe monopoly or
Scrabble Scrabble
how's Willy is so good it Willie say hi
he can't he can't talk we're newlyweds
how do we build a strong marriage my
parents gave us two words of advice that
have been very helpful mutual generosity
can you speak Spanish no well except I
guess I just did if you could speak any
language what would it be probably
Spanish did you have braces yes for
three years Coke or Pepsi Diet Dr Pepper
dinosaurs are dragons dinos favourite
infinity real numbers is there gonna be
more crash course with you yes more
literature this summer we're reading all
these books what are you reading right
now this it's so good feelings on socks
I love them how excited are you for
VidCon very less than 90 days to go
llamas or alpacas llamas
what's your Starbucks order how can I
have like a like a regular just a large
regular coffee just just black coffee
thank you fifty questions four minutes
ago see you on Friday